congratulations uh you guys have been
just a joy to watch um but also your
friendship the way that it's evolved
what is gonna happen post show
we're gonna have to keep hanging out he
better answer my phone calls that's what
i just say
what have been your thoughts just on the
entire season how are you feeling it i
mean i feel like this week we had a lot
of time to reflect on how magical this
season has been yes and it truly is
such
uh not only inspirational season but
such a sentimental one for me and i'm so
lucky yeah how are you feeling about
everything i feel so good honestly this
this whole journey it has just been such
a joy and i really i'm taking away so
many things right now i mean it's it's
crazy to think it's ending tonight but i
mean it's brought so much new life into
me that i'm i'm so grateful for every
second of it yeah what is a celebrity
who is a celebrity you would love to see
for next season oh i'm i'm voting for my
talk co-host jerry o'connell 100
jerry i want you on dancing at the stars
next season
i love that and obviously thoughts on
the winner iman we love iman i am so
proud of him
you know every week he just got better
and better and i feel like tonight he
showed why he should be holding that
mirror ball trophy i'm so proud of him
everyone in the finale did such an
incredible job but you know iman and
daniella daniela did some magical
choreography out there iman just had
that spirit that you want to root for
you know he's he's awesome awesome thank
you guys thank you congratulations you
guys are amazing
so cool